I know you don't listen.
I think if you never talked about Sandy Hook,
you'd have no problems.
I really do believe that.
I believe there'd be problems.
I think people would look down on you and call you a right wing lunatic and all
sorts of other things,
which they don't even know.
When I knew you when I first knew you,
you were getting arrested for going after George Bush.
I remember when George,
you are not a right one guy.
Ask Him a question.
He had me rush.
Well you,
yeah.
Were you were asking him a pertinent question about the CFR in his dad's drug.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
And this was a guy that was running for president as a Republican and you,
you were getting arrested for questioning and contra the CFR.
But my point is you weren't,
you weren't a tie to a party.
You were trying to find the truth.
And I,
when I,
when I aligned with Trump,
that's when all hell broke loose.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was part of it.
I think that was definitely Hillary admits.
She looked at my whole bio and shit.
Shani Hook,
hit him on that right now.
Uh,
do juice still communicate with Trump?
Not In a while and I shot it becomes a big issue.
I mean I obviously communicate with surrogates should people that talk to Trump,
I mean don jr was on Tucker Carlson last night.
They were talking about Ma'am saying what happened was wrong and the fact that
they've used me as the way to start the casual society and then,
and then,
and then I'm gonna Imagine are never supposed to block somebody from banking if
they have a good record,
it's not fraud.
Here's a whole other story.
I had an a plus plus rating with my shopping cart and bank accounts that I had
for 22 years and banks looked at it and said,
we've quite frankly never seen anybody with a credit rating.
The shy cause you'd ever even do chargebacks with our shopping cart.
People do that.
What does that mean?
Chargebacks point is we have the best credit.
There is a group out of Boston,
which I'm not going to mention here for your show and things,
but we're preparing litigation against who does the ratings to she grit rating
system for like Taliban al Qaeda,
the Mafia that's,
that's given a bank executives two days before paypal bandage,
they put a hate designation for the southern poverty law center.
Shang I'm basically a terrorist so when they call you a hate personality,
it needs a terrorist in Interpol show all over the western world.
I am listed and we would sent documents out of England and out of the u s that
we were sent this by High Level Bank of people that are freaked out.
We make contacts,
lawyers checks that they can't believe it.
They have designated me as an international terrorist and that's how they took
five of my six bank accounts and got me down to one bank account with perfect
credit Shang.
You cannot take money on your shopping cart and forced to.com for your products,
t shirts,
books,
whatever.
You,
you aren't allowed to be in commerce because you are a terrorist.
And what do they use to define terrorist h?
It's classified symbols and we got some of the documents is hate,
h is hate.
And then just let me just decide arbitrarily that you're a hateful person that
you promote hate.
No judge,
no jury.
It's the global Chinese social score.
That's what they're all testing for here.
But this is what we were talking about.
That's very important.
This is actually,
this is actually dangerous to give people the ability to define people without
any strict rigid qualifications,
without anything that you can point to on paper.
If I was a convicted murderer and got out of prison,
I started online storage,
sell t shirts,
right?
If I was Charlie Manson,
he had like four TV specials on,
on,
you know,
uh,
CBS on 60 minutes and I was a kid.
I watched Charlie Manson.
I don't think he was allowed to get paid for those though.
I think that was part of the thing because he's involved in,
well,
we'll share,
they have laws on that.
But the point is he would do her all the reverse shows.
The point is Hitler.
Basically it was the number one thing on the history channel when they first
launched it so you can hear what Hitler has to say even though we know he's a
bad guy.
Well why can't you read Alex Challenge?
I have to say because they have found what I talk about as effective.
It gets people thinking and they want it shut down because we've,
we've relaunched populism,
Info wars has done this.
My audience has 1776 worldwide populism,
anti globalism,
anti-communism anti China and the big tech companies,
Google and apple and all of them have publicly moved to China and they publicly
agreed the sensor and control the population.
This is in the nose and that's why Tim Cook got so mad at me and I made a huge
issue to Trump and I shouldn't report to the president.
I know he got and that that's what happened on that Sunday night when they said
that's it,
we're done with Jones.
We have to take him down because I got investigations going at the national
security level,
sending big reports,
the president through law firms of Reuters and AP and then the articles which he
wasn't getting where China has given the code keys by apple just last year,
uh,
and is moving their database there and all the code keys have been given to the
Chinese government.
And Apple says,
I just part of being there and Google's building dragon fly project help since
the entire population with a social credit score.
They're already testing in Venezuela with China and they're going to bring it
here and everything you do in live time will be controlled.
And you know,
all the big airlines now are putting cameras in that watch you while you're on
the airplane.
Let me stop you because you rent.
And again,
I am renting.
That's okay.
You think they're using sandy hook as an excuse to get you off the air and to
censor you and to take away your ability to make income.
Not because of that,
but using that as an excuse because of the other things that you do.
Oh they like targeting things like Google and talking about things that you
talking about where were there in China and China's allow,
they're allowing China to censor the population.
I'm just telling,
I'm not against Google or apple.
They're that.
They've did a lot of cool things.
I'm saying stop it.
Congress told you 10 years ago you were built here in the u s with Darpa money.
Don't go help China do this stuff.
Don't be evil.
Well I let me tell you something cause I knew someone who worked at Google.
I know someone who used to work at Google,
I should say.
Their thought process was that Google is going,
if they don't bring Google to China in a sense it form,
they're going to copy Google.
This was there were the real worry because China copies everything.
I mean their intellectual copyright ball steal it better now.
True.
But this is what they're saying.
Wait,
what about that Joe?
But let me,
let me explain something from the point of view of Google as a business.
And I don't necessarily,
I'm not saying I agree with this cause I don't reach more apple juice.
Get some apple juice and your system fella.
Um,
they were thinking,
and this is what I was talking to a woman who was a very high level executive
and she was saying that they're going to steal it if we don't work with them.
They're just going to steal Google and take the code and make their own version
of it.
So them as a business,
they're like,
this is inevitable.
They're going to do it anyway.
We're just going to give in to their censorship demands.
I don't agree with it.
I don't think it's a good idea,
but I don't know what I would do if I was Google.
I'll tell them,
you'll tell what,
I'll tell you a little tissue.
What should they do for China?
You're dead on with what that person told you.
When I had the globalist 15 years ago,
20 years ago,
tried to buy me off 10 million a year,
you know,
whatever.
Um,
by the way,
cheers.
Cheers brother.
Anyway,
when they did all that
well,
they did all that.
What were they trying to do?
Who's trying to buy you out?
Well,
I can't get into it.
You can have private meetings and the judge journalistic stuff off record,
but I mean everybody gets business offers like Alex,
you're going to influence things by being on the inside.
If you don't join this and helps save the planet and do all these big things.
My Dad,
I've got the same speech when he was in high school already.
Ut had planned to let me tell you about that.
We'll get to that later,
but if you don't join us,
then the bad guys that are in the system are going to win.
That's how they call object because that's how those people you're talking to
are probably pretty good person.
That person at Google,
they've had hundreds of their top engineers quit over this because here's the
thing.
China in 1949 was nationalist and and capitalist and our own CIA been
declassified,
leftist,
the Ford Foundation.
That's what's above the CIA helped put the Chai comms and power.
It took him decades to get running water and toilets.
They have no environmental standards,
no rules.
They've had all of our investment.
They've been built up because the Chinese commies,
we'll do whatever the globalist wine,
when you go and you are in China,
they make you become state run to get 0% tax corporate.
Okay?
That's what Trump's trying to lower ours.
Just to be competitive.
China has 0% corporate tax.
Look it up.
Now,
if you become state sponsored state run show,
they're claiming,
oh,
show that China doesn't rape us of our technology.
We're going to go over there and spread our legs to them even more.
So it's not a rape.
We're willing and we're going to take you along with us.
So the idea that,
well if we don't give it to them,
they're just gonna rip it off.
So let us go,
really give them all the big secrets and,
and have Google last year tell the Pentagon we're not going to help you with Ai,
autonomous drones.
But Google gave them all the latest Ai.
Yeah.
And I'm getting more sophisticated stuff in a moment.
Gave them all the sophisticated AI and now China announces they've got all these
AI drones that are autonomous and all these AI weapons systems should erector.